yet don't bite him yet
don't buy
[Music]
all right in Indonesia there's this
farmer he's 61 years old and uh his
nickname is the Playboy King what do you
think that is oh [ __ ] is he like a hot
farmer I don't know you tell me I'll
show you a picture of him he has like 12
hot ass daughters
huh the Playboy King ladies and
gentlemen he looks like he does magic or
something
he definitely has a magical thing about
him he looks like a warlord in the area
yeah it's really easy to cast for
certain movies is he like a pimp he's
not a pimp no oh no Playboy okay here's
the thing his name's a Playboy king
that's kind of his like Village nickname
yeah all right he uh he doesn't do
anything that's necessarily play because
when you think Playboy you think oh this
guy like gets a lot like ladies and he's
got a sick authentic vintage collection
of all the Playboys that's what I was
thinking no that would be pretty cool
though but it's the best nasty girl ring
in the [ __ ] Village bro he's not
doing anything sexual adulterous oh why
how do you get a nickname like the
Playboy king without doing anything
adulterous he's having a good time he's
a farmer he is a farmer yeah he probably
has the best Harvest bro he provides for
the whole building so they call him
Playboy King for having the best Harvest
a rabbit farmer a what a rabbit farmer
what do you mean by adulterous oh the
bunny the logo Playboy Bunny so he he
owns a lot of bunnies
he like plays tag
he likes to play he like he rides um kid
bicycles oh sure there's all fun games
yeah like I mean by adulterous like uh
he likes to have a good time
boning a bunch of women
premaritaly oh there's a bone oh he
holds him after they're married he's
he's married to a lot of women he's been
married to a lot of women that is a
adulteress
oh oh but he has he's added a ton of
wives yeah so he's about to get married
again
and what number 70 do you think this is
26 17 35 let's use the closest 35 12.
the the farthest farthest has to get
punished though yeah farthest has to get
punished [ __ ] I'll say 12. okay I said
12. oh you did yeah I'll go I'll go oh
boy King for 12. what kind of King has
12. how big is the village almost at 70.
he said 70. well you could say race cars
here so I'll give you guys a hint 22.
are you locked on 12 before this evening
I don't know the record for who's been
married the most is um some guy I forgot
what country he's in but he's been
married 29 times what number marriage do
you think this guy's about to have 29 is
the world record oh okay whoa 28 25. you
think he's about to get married I said
26 earlier when he said seven so you're
28 25. 25 20. no his is 12 still don't
[ __ ] around yeah mine was 35. 35 and you
know what I'll be I'll be you gave me
another hint so I got to change it to 26
now okay
26.7 [ __ ] 27. all right now that it's
all locked in now that it's all locked
it's locked up
out of everybody that who guessed the
lowest I was the lowest dude I was 12.
okay no I don't want to do 12 I don't
wanna you were 12.
you're in the middle yeah because
they're 12. I'm 35 he's 70. okay okay
you're saying to the same numbers that
we said in the beginning
12 70. okay but I'm not locking it here
after you give us a clue we're allowed
to change it yeah
I'm 27. 27 27.
records 29 yeah so there's but changing
that bro just pick a number dude far in
the world records 29 because if we're
all changing I'm changing I will tell
you this he is breaking that record by
the way 30. 35 because if we're all
changing I'm gonna go to 200. but you
might be past it
I don't know dude we all lost
anymore I just want to see somebody else
lose okay what's the number what's the
punishment what's the punishment eat a
whole bag of Hot Cheetos in two bites
nice I like it okay cool that's set all
the numbers are set this man is about to
be married for the 88th time oh
you gave us a [ __ ] up clue you said
the world record was 20 minutes
it was
so he already beat the world record ages
ago they didn't record it they didn't
know yeah this guy's about to be married
for the 88th time
the woman must be like well he's not
gonna he also has remarried people that
he's divorced he remarried them the
woman that he's gonna marry for the 80th
time he was married to her at the 86th
can we see all of his Harem of women he
doesn't have him he hasn't one at a time
because he believes in in a one at a
time he believes in one at a time yeah
whose is this so he just wants to [ __ ] a
lot well which numbers are we going with
yeah we all chose 80 different numbers
dude I said 70. what was just
objectively what was the lowest number
yelled two of us were 12. two of us work
Nick forgot that I said 12. we're both
12 say 12. we gotta wrap our arms like
this and then we gotta eat the hot
Cheetos you gotta eat the whole bag in
two bites that's crazy
in your mouth you get two chances you
guys are gonna get it crazy
don't bite don't bite ready Nick he's
already going fight okay don't bite him
yet don't bite him yet
don't buy you gotta make it in the mouth
bro keep your mouth taped open and then
bite to the camera please
please bite the camera
I'll do water dude no that's bite one
that's bite one
all right I got Cheetos all over our
[ __ ] desk over here you guys are
ruining your appetite don't spin it back
into the bag hey that's disgusting
it's turned into JK party suddenly oh
God these are so stale oh are they are
they old give me a new bag dude
I can't even chew the first one
I'm actually really hungry right now
I'm starving dude the amount of just
[ __ ] all over here I'm gonna take a
photo I didn't want to make a mess bro I
didn't want to make a mess
was a good guy I was able to fit a lot
of Cheetos in my mouth I'm glad you
locked it in yeah because this guy's a g
sorry you guys had to do that no it's
okay so yeah these buildings together
this guy his first marriage when he was
14. whoa so that's also how he racked up
numbers so fast it started in Indonesia
he was getting married so normal then
he's getting married really early and he
just kept doing it because he believes
uh that he gains spiritual knowledge he
doesn't believe it through his [ __ ]
through uh through the number of women
he's like uh falling in love with would
you well this one must be a stage then
yeah
he's 61. holy [ __ ] 80 something you have
kids with them
oh he's like the new Genghis Khan dude
yeah dude 88 was no children it doesn't
say it doesn't say he has kids but uh
that's really hard amazing that's
amazing well he's just really good at
pulling out but yeah the the guy who had
the the guy who had the previous record
he was a Baptist Minister and yeah 29
times
they ain't got [ __ ] on Mormons but also
for the record they are vacuuming right
now
are you really vacuuming now bro look at
this mess bro like this full that's why
I didn't want to happen yo
I tried my best somebody had finesse on
the other side of the table I tried my
best this is half the bag
I tried my best dude 88 times man that's
a lot I mean some of these
There You Go full vacuum y'all
and we're good baby yeah or Mike will
still get us
so he'll be married for maybe like less
than a year for each of these like so
he'll just marry him divorce him and
then want them to evolve and he'll marry
him again I want them to evolve it's not
always him sometimes they divorce him
because they don't like him they don't
know his behavior or something but the
crazy thing is he's finding that many
people that are willing to get married
yeah it might be a novelty thing it's
like hey did you marry him yet yeah you
know what I mean also maybe in his area
he's like maybe he's like a little
affluent because he's he owns the farm
or something like that that's also crazy
where like you date someone and they're
like oh how many like boyfriend or
girlfriends have you had I've had 65
wives and then the person's like oh I'm
down to be here 66. that's crazy lucky
number is he in a small village uh it
doesn't say if it's a small village you
might have [ __ ] the whole town yeah
definitely a couple of them are sisters
West Java Province so if you haven't
heard it this guy married more women
than the last guy murdered oh yeah
because they he murdered 70 girls
reference JK news video that might be
uploaded and not in this corner that you
can click right here he's married more
women than most people have ever
murdered that's true
geez he's married more women than most
people have ever dated
yeah definitely but he's like a rapper
the crazy thing that I don't really know
is like is this all documented or is he
just like saying that he could be
there's no [ __ ] like uh unless
they're doing notaries and stuff like
marriage like that's a lot of and the
fact that he really was having weddings
every time that's so much worse [ __ ]
rock rocks in a basket somewhere and
then keep track of all the chicks he
knows he has tick marks
yeah yeah yeah their names are just
numbers but it's it's kind of cool that
like you wonder what would make a guy
want to do that and of course he has
that belief that he's gaining spiritual
knowledge makes sense if he has that
belief but every time is uh in sickness
and in health to death do us part every
time every time or whatever the
Indonesian version is I know what are
the vowels in the Indonesian one and I
didn't know divorce was cool next year
or kanji or yeah I thought it was like a
strict country where divorce is like
shunned upon and you can't do that and
then like can you imagine being the 88
girl like this time this time it's the
real one yeah yeah maybe he doesn't tell
them there's no way that women doesn't
know that it's his 70 because if it's a
village everybody knows like it's a 79th
guy yeah they're all keeping count too
or maybe all the girls are like you know
what I'm the special one that's gonna
lock I could fix him yeah yeah I can fix
him I mean
but he's also probably just like you
think he's a real free spirit maybe
unless it's been four women that he's
just constantly marrying and divorcing
over and over and over
that's a racket yeah yeah that's that's
not no Guinness World Record here for
that yeah that's for women but yeah man
give it up for the Playboy King
foreign